your realm of expertise is so
fascinating to me the amount of time
that i walk around in the day and just
wonder what's real and what's happening
and then thinking back to when i was a
kid and looking up to the sky and goes
thinking to myself it goes on for
infinity but what is at the end of
infinite not it doesn't i can't oh my
brain
is that what you did when you were a kid
did you like did you look up at the sky
and just go i need to know
yeah i mean that that's how i got into
science it was astronomy just like you
just looking up at the night sky
something captured my imagination and
fortunately for me i made the connection
i thought well
actually learning about these points of
light and what they are is science
and so i started paying attention at
school to science because i wanted to
know about astronomy and also science
fiction actually i grew up
you know star wars was the huge thing
when i was nine ten years old um and and
so i connected all that as well and
thought it's all the same thing
and
i want to know more about it that's the
wonderful thing about astronomy as you
say is the more you learn about those
points of light in the sky the more
wonderful they become and in the morning
at the moment that the planets are up
kind of early morning then jupiter for
example you know if you look at that
just through a pair of binoculars or a
small telescope you see the moons
and then you realize that one of those
moons europa
has an ocean below its surface which has
got more water than all the oceans of
the earth combined who is the size of
europa similar to earth it's smaller
it's kind of almost a small planet sized
so it's smaller than the earth but it's
just water beneath the surface i was at
jpl a few weeks ago actually where they
build the space probes and um they're
building a thing called europa clipper
now which is going to go to that moon
and one of the reasons is because it's
one of our prime candidates for life
so then you know the point of light that
you're looking at might have life on it
or in it in the ocean and off you go did
that also
make you wonder when you looked out to
the sky whether or not there were other
entities out there too well yeah and um
you know microbes might be really common
so we also as we speak there's a robot
called perseverance on mars
which is now in a river delta which just
arrived an ancient river delta and it's
it's taking samples below the surface
because three and a half billion years
ago that surface was underwater and so
we want to know whether there are signs
of life and the most amazing thing about
that mission
is that perseverance the rover is the
first bit so it's packaging up samples
and it's going to leave them on the
surface of mars
and then
the next thing that another mission is
going to go and land another lander on
mars which is going to go and collect
the samples
put them in a rocket and the rocket is
going to be believe it or not catapulted
up
off the surface and then they're going
to light the rocket and it's going to
fly into orbit around mars and then
they're going to send another mission
which is going to go and find this thing
which has got the samples in it which is
only about the size of a baseball
and then it's going to find it in orbit
around miles get it and then bring it
back to earth and ultimately it's going
to crash land in utah in the desert and
then they're going to go and find that
and bring it back to the laboratory to
look for signs of life on mars it's the
most incredible it's called mars temple
return and the more you talk about it
the more crazy
right that does sound like quite the
choreographed
um
mission i've heard you talking about
this before and thinking that maybe
there's
going to be information in that in those
samples and those core samples to
how life began and it might help us
understand how our life began is that
accurate yeah the the interesting thing
about mars is that if life began on mars
it probably began around the same time
that it began on earth so three and a
half four billion years ago but on earth
so kind of paradoxically it's much
harder to look back in time because
earth's active it's got weather it's got
you know volcanoes plate tectonics all
this stuff so the surface is constantly
being renewed and so it's very very hard
to get samples from earth
of earth as it was three and a half to
four billion years ago it's almost
impossible
whereas on mars it stopped being
geologically active about three and a
half billion years ago so it's been in
deep freeze and so these river deltas
that perseverance is roving across now
are pristine river deltas from
three and a half billion years ago
they're time capsules so it might be
easier to understand the origin of life
if it began on mars it might be much
easier to do so than it is on our own
planet
how far down are those
the water now is probably is way deeper
but um these this was surface water
three and a half billion years ago yeah
so the idea is that if there were
microbes in that river delta
then their remains are the traces
they've left
will be just below the surface and
that's why we're taking these samples to
bring back to earth
so okay so if we can look back to that
time and say maybe this is an indication
of how life started
would it be
far-fetched to think that if we just
look to how we're doing it right now
to find life that that's just how life
started then too
so like extraterrestrials or another
somebody you're finding another planet
to to live on could it just be someone
from another planet coming to figure out
and like oh look here we can this is how
it started somebody visited and said
this looks like a nice home it's one of
the one of the big questions we have
about the origin of life is of of course
how often did it happen
um
sold a system like ours it obviously
happened here
or did it
because we know that
sat material is transferred between the
planets so we have martian meteorites on
the earth we have bits of the earth on
mars so that we've not found them but
because bits of mars land on earth we
assume
the bits of earth land on mars and so
it's not completely impossible
that life began once
on earth or mars
and got transferred and so we the first
thing we want to know if we find signs
of life on mars is is it the same
so does it look you know does it have
dna is it in some sense the same as the
life on earth or is it different so was
there a different genesis how many
different ways are there of being alive
we don't know because we have only one
example which is earth so these are
profound questions and then to go on to
your next question then then you start
saying well but what what about what's
the chance that given
microbes the origin of life little cells
or something like that
what are the chances of those cells
ultimately getting together into things
like you and me
which are these hugely complex things
the most complex things we know of
anywhere in the universe the things that
can have a conversation
and think and
feel and bring meaning to the universe
in a very real sense
and all we know again is that it took
about over three billion years from the
origin of life
on earth to get anything more complex
than a single cell
it's about three billion years it's a
quarter of the age of the universe
and so
what i talk about in the live show
actually is if i was to guess
we could we don't know but if i was to
guess how many civilizations there are
in a galaxy like the milky way with 400
billion suns and countless trillions of
planets i'd guess there might be a
handful maybe even one which is us
i think the chances of civilizations
appearing on planets it's a big ask when
you think about it isn't it i mean to
think you know it's one thing to have
some chemicals getting together and
turning into a cell and it's a living
thing and it's a huge deal there it's a
big thing in itself yeah but then the
idea that those cells decide to
collaborate together and build
spaceships
is a whole other
question right and create these complex
missions to get things off mars
so then would it be accurate to say that
if you thought that there could be a
handful or even one civilization in a
galaxy that there would be one to a
handful in every galaxy the milky way is
not
that
atypical that we know of um
our estimate by the way for the number
of galaxies in the piece of the universe
we can see which is called the
observable universe it's two trillion
right
so so yeah i think the milky way is
fairly typical we don't really see
anything that's massively unusual so i
think that i'm sure
as sure as i can be that there are
civilizations out there somewhere in the
universe but the question really if we
want to ever meet them or we really want
to you know
see extraterrestrial life the question
is how many are in our neighborhoods
and i'm being loose with the word
neighborhood because the milky way
galaxy is 150 000 light years across or
something like that with four
400 billion suns so it's big but let's
say that's a neighborhood imagine if
we're the only one in there um that's a
it's it's quite a
it's there's quite a responsibility we
have
i would say if that's the case i was
asked to give the um
to give the intro um the the cop 26
climate summit um so it was quite an
honor actually they said to me what
would you say to the world leaders um if
you've got one message to them about the
the progress we need to make a climate
what would it be
and i said this i said that as far as i
know if you it's a possibility at least
so let's say it's our operating premise
that we are the only civilization in the
milky way galaxy at the moment
and that means that this planet this
little speck of dust notwithstanding its
physical insignificance is almost
indescribably valuable because it could
be the only place where atoms have got
together to think
and feel and in a very deep sense bring
meaning to the universe because i would
argue that you need things as complex as
human brains you need thoughts
to have meaning
and so if you collectively world leaders
through inaction or deliberate action
remove us from this world
then you may be responsible for
eliminating meaning in a galaxy of 400
billion stars potentially forever
that's the responsibility that you have
and that's an example of why i think
that science is so valuable it's not
because it has the answers to everything
we don't have the answers to everything
science science is fundamentally a
humble pursuit it's based on the idea
that we don't know everything therefore
we try to find out and do research
but it does give us perspective
my great hero carl sagan said that
astronomy is a humbling and character
building experience so it's humbling
because it tells us that we're tiny
suspected dust
but it's character building because it
says that we might also be extremely
valuable and we might underestimate our
cosmic significance
and so we have a tremendous
responsibility i think it's a good
working assumption and i don't think
that you know the more
the more world leaders and our
politicians the more perspective they
have and the more the more they
understand
the potential tragedy
of damage in this world i think that i
really do think the better they behave
they just need to do a bit of astronomy
i'd launch them into space well you know
people talk about commercial space maybe
we'll talk about it but one of the great
benefits for me
would be to launch every world leader
into space before they start so they can
look at the earth from space and get a
sense of its beauty and fragility and
ultimately i think its significance
and then um
and then you know we can choose maybe we
can vote which ones to bring back but
probably speaking i'd bring most of them
back again
and just say there you go now you've
seen what you are responsible for